[Music]
Australia Charlie Parker Charlie Parker
right is coyote napalm that's good
how's it going no good chili thank you
for sitting down with me
it's a pleasure napalm brought her she
said you wanted me Tarly Parker and my
first thought was I would but that he
did and then she that's my bird and then
bird is the word
yeah so uh yeah it's weird in a hotel in
Melbourne if I sound a little different
is it just a burden to backgrounds I'm
gonna show that sparkle in the chain
feature this is the first time I wish
that I had I wish is a video process
it's a bird I'm trying now I feel like a
new new ways Coco beware I'm trying to
I'm right with it this is the does he
say any words Oliver all birds don't say
he just no yeah he's I mean like he can
talk to you but it's all in bird
gibberish once you told me about him
since we were doing in if you like [ __ ]
like that I looked him up he has a solid
web presence and he's mentioned he's
mentioned in lots of interviews of yours
he has more friends than I do sometimes
like people who stop me in the street
it's like someone fanning out and
they'll be like what's up Charlie like
completely not even acknowledged really
easier to connect with an animal you
know you can be very one-sided let's
just let all of your fears off into this
animal and now you decide you could just
talk to the bird you know that's a huge
thing though internet animals is it when
yes people will say an Instagram account
for dogs or cats and then these dogs get
famous like that chicken I had his head
cut off in the
stayed alive for ages and I was in like
whiskey advertising you should wait what
that was so kind of like you know about
that there's like a famous chicken they
survived after his hair got cut off for
how long I don't like long enough to do
advertising campaigns unless they just
you know wait it had no brain it was
like I think like enough of its brain or
some [ __ ] was like still attacks I'm
thinking more like somebody has a cute
dog and then they just start taking
pictures of the dog and that just
catches on mm I had a you know like Iggy
Pop has won for his cockatoo yeah yeah
biggie pop it's hilarious have you ever
done press with a famous dog ah I don't
think so no no not that I can think of I
did I did one initially I turned it down
but then I'm like I'll search this dog
and I looked at his web reach and I said
this is a great opportunity to branch
out of supply you [ __ ] I found this uh
he found it Mike the headless chicken
Mike April 20th 1945 to March 17 1947
also known as miracle Mike oh so he
lived almost two years mm-hmm
although what that was going was thought
by many to be a hoax the birds owner
took him to the University of Utah in
Salt Lake City to establish the facts oh
wow that's when there was no internet
it was pre-internet that was in the 40s
you couldn't just go you couldn't just
say you can just post it online
nobody believed you had to send he was a
son he was sitting he was sitting he was
writing letters to everybody
Jim you won't believe me we're here at
day 67 and the chicken is alive what is
happening over here with this bird on my
shoulder is he sleeping he's grinding
his beak okay that's when people grind
their teeth in this yeah I wasn't but it
wasn't irritating it just sounded like
I'm like is he biting my ear but I just
don't feel anything cause it's a sound
you know what no it adds
that's an interesting dynamic so that so
the conversation said it interview
nobody wants that you first met we met
in Austin Texas
yeah ssangshik eat a banana two Chiquita
bananas
well no no that was before that before I
I had this web series and I was doing
oh [ __ ] in the alleyway and I
interviewed you all but and everyone was
high as [ __ ] oh alright but I was was I
did a bunch of interviews and I wasn't
prepared at all you know I don't know I
haven't looked back at it but probably
something like how'd you guys meet music
like a random like dark it wasn't a dark
out who's doing a daytime I would never
shoot in a dark and it was like opening
opening up about how his love life
wasn't like hating on Sydney's oh really
yeah oh man I'm glad I did so that's
been a longtime thing between Melbourne
yeah it was a bad interview man okay I
got a look back at that I think I had
that hard drive at home where I had
webseries project going called talking
to strangers and I had talked to a bunch
of people my friend Callie she's my
publicist at the time she'll produced it
Callie green and she was talking with
all these different musicians but some
of them I was very uninformed and
probably sound like a [ __ ] and I feel
bad now knowing especially how much I
hate it when I do an interview and it's
obvious that the person and then I met
you all get either year after that or
two years after that
okay players okay and we all met there
and then you all perform you know like
this is this is really amazing this is
great music thank you
the other net sound like for white
people with my fans like in a you know
like after a show and you do like this
CD signings issues people just like
still confused don't believe it's not
butter like you know kind of [ __ ] let's
just like anyway yeah I put on a great
show
what is this you sound like something
you you're able to sound the same you
take care of your voice uh
I mean right now because I'm having some
time off yeah it's a little like making
the Macy Gray spectrum of my vocal range
Road
yeah but generally not as much I can't
so yeah so the guys can get [ __ ] up
yeah yeah stay hydrated so is the voice
it's interesting to hear where it say is
there a time range like you follow fight
you know fighters have their fighting
weight yeah my sister's a the Victorian
champion from white I fighting I won't
get into that
yeah yeah the way she is crazy but yet
so fighters have their fighting weight
and they have their walking around
weight so a tauren singer you saying you
have your you know your Turing voice and
you have your walking around like some
fighters might fight it 155 but they
walk around at 185 well you sound good
in your to it but now you said you and
you're walking around [ __ ] well you're
better than most people but you're not
at your best
well it's it's more um it's more like a
preservation and saying like yeah I can
still sing but I can't do six shows in a
row and fly and yeah do you really have
to look after your [ __ ] if you're gonna
do that mmm well uh yeah so you do like
what five shows and take a day off to
let your voice like well I mean now it's
at a point where
I can be a diva and demand more downtime
in between shows but it has been pretty
hectic especially like South by
Southwest where you're doing multiple
shows a day you know it's pretty
draining yeah yeah southwest of where do
y'all make money you got free [ __ ]
occasional use this nut I mean three
harvick you some Ravens dud I go there
button okay you know I have occasion a
sponsored gig that keeps me but it says
it's just a lot of other [ __ ] what do
you just say you want to do this yeah
it's fun it's fine exposure but there's
so many especially I mean I'm I get it
maybe four bands first it's when you're
just starting out it we start it's uh
but it's a fun time but it's such a it's
really huge in a [ __ ] I'm like
Webster's definition of a [ __ ] is
South by Southwest have you what is your
first time out there the when I met you
2012 that was the first time we never
been overseas two artists I mean during
yeah yeah yeah so that was kind of like
we did that and then we do that first
you I think so yes maybe you guys maybe
like the UK in London I think so far has
been the biggest audience but between
like New York LA London please in we
sought out the Opera House in Sydney
though which yes you know that was like
one of my favorite shows I've ever done
you born a raise in Melbourne yeah well
I lived in a place called Mount Beauty
Mount beauty yeah yeah is it is it
really beautiful is it ironic is an
ironic name like what fat dudes names
yeah um it is very beautiful but it's a
valley and ugliest mountain is Mount
Beauty so yeah yeah it looks like it's
got giant shaved mark so if I didn't
like satellite dishes and stuff but
everything else is beautiful
it's like Alpine
yeah kind of like maybe like what
Colorado what really yeah you know yeah
so I lived there for a while okay I
can't take the bird in my earring yeah
snapping he breaks people yes it's just
a grind and if he was just doing it I
could handle that what that what yeah
how many songs is the bird Charlie
Parker featured on uh well I'm in the
hall lost record choose your weapon
yeah pretty much all the vocal checking
I did with him on my shoulder
yeah so there'd be a little bit of bleed
but I think just Prince mini kid yeah
yeah okay
Oh Prince Medicaid and creations part
one I'm gonna reel issen now yeah we
listen cuz maybe I heard it and then
thought it was a you know bird sound
effect what does an owl - there's me see
ya making friends with Studio L is a
killer no I was like out the at the
front of the studio and I was having a
break oh boy go checking and I was
singing with it and then yeah Bend on my
bass player had like a zoom recorder and
managed to capture it so yeah yeah
animal kingdom's next was was next
koalas I don't know they sound kind of
like satanic this much do most native
Australian I don't sound like they're
really I haven't met one yet see I used
to live will watt life carrots when I
lived in the amount Beauty so it looked
off to like baby Joey's and good
wildlife what Charis Charis okay yeah so
rehabilitating native animals that have
been injured or whatever and then like
releasing them back into the wild it was
cool yeah mmm what's the crazy what's it
tell me a crazy story about an injured
animal um I mean the scariest one for me
was a wedge tailed eagle
yeah
they have a wingspan of about 3 meters
and basically they they eat roadkill
that have been hit by cars and then they
get too full you know like when you have
a food coma from eating too much and
then everything kind of slows down so
they try and fly off when cars come but
because they were like really full they
can't fly Oh stupid you gotta eat so
there was one that had been hit by a car
like full-grown and um we had a bird
avery that had like sugar gliders and
owls and stuff but because the bird of
prey don't eat pretty much everything
else that was in there so he had to be
in its own cage which was on the kitchen
bench and so you'd come you come this
was when I was still in like high school
you come downstairs to like eat your
cereal before you go to school and this
eagle was just like staring you down I
was like really scared of it that's
frightening yeah because they're so
powerful they're beautiful but just like
I was frightening mildly terrified but
then so we looked after for about three
weeks and then released it off we're
like the power gliders fly off watch
them fly away that was [ __ ] amazing
been in like caged like for three weeks
on the kitchen bench
did they ever come back and remember you
guys um I've had that with a Kroy oh
yeah
mmm it was a scratch from a crow I Han
read and I released darkness I've seen
her since then she comes back and kind
of I only saw her one other time wait no
I don't get it scratched you and then
you put the tattoo line over the scratch
yeah it was my first tattoo that's dull
yeah sometimes I have like old women
coming for like China oh really
random old ladies I think it's like the
licking you know boom women that were at
a show or just women in the street no no
like just worried they try to fix it and
they will lick your at their finger it
is not just something
forward and comfortable like friends
with anyone you know yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
Simon maybe Kate alkies play out yeah
hey just before it was um in a band he
was working in an aquarium I used to get
really bored and so he at the Melbourne
Accord
yeah I've been I went my first trip out
here 20 2011 right yeah um yeah and he
would have a competition with other
people that work there to see how many
times I could say mate like when someone
was buying tickets like alright mate uh
that'll be uh
that'll be $12 mate so if you just go
through there mate and like have Italian
yeah just to [ __ ] with tourists yeah and
see how many they could because they
were just bored as [ __ ] yeah but he also
have like fed Turtles and sharks and
[ __ ] Simon maven is a very intriguing
young man like I've been in a band with
him for like five years and then every
now and then he would just like you'll
say so where are you a curve ball of
information about himself I don't think
it was him it was when I when I went to
when I for my first time out here in
2011 when I went to the aquarium that's
how I found out there was a high minimum
wage in Australia cuz the guy taking our
picture at the aquarium said where do
you live I said I live in New York he
said I'm going to New York so from New
Yorker one of Miami to Chicago to Austin
Texas
lay in Seattle and you will you you take
pictures at the aquarium are you talking
a six-cd American vacation because in
America if you work with the aquarium
you also vacation if the equator I was
John what this job you can travel like
that nobody with that type of a job in
America travel maybe they'll go one
place okay yeah I'm going to Myrtle
Beach what do we did six flags really
gonna break me turn it tell me tell me
up a little bit yeah turn my yeah yeah
give my give my voice right yeah yeah
yeah see geek is an app you can get
tickets to [ __ ] whatever man you want to
see Hamilton you want to see me you want
to see the Phoenix Suns you want to see
the Charlotte Hornets you want to see
the Milwaukee Bucks you want to see the
Kansas City chief you want to see the
Chicago Blackhawks you want to see the
Cleveland Browns you want to see the
Cincinnati Bengals you want to see the
Cincinnati Reds you want to see the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers you want to see the
New York Giants you want to see the New
York Jets you want to see the New York
Knicks go to SeatGeek
sea geek it makes us move shows you
everything
Transparency smooth man Oh guess what
guess what I negotiated for you all
guess what I did go Satan for you all
guess what I did negotiated for you all
$20 off $20 rebate that's what I did
they tried they tried to say 15 they
actually tried to say 10 I said [ __ ] no
I said 20 they tried to meet in the
middle at 50 and I said no I said it's
either $20 while I'm walking out of this
Dunkin Donuts right now to get your $20
rebate on tickets download the free CD
gap go there's a Settings tab and click
Add a promo code
it's a promo code Rambler SeatGeek will
send you $20 after you've made your
first ticket purchase download the free
CD gap
it's a promo code Rambler are ampl e o
is fascinating one of those people that
people just open up to you and start
telling you all sorts of crazy [ __ ]
about their lives not all let's hit the
pins and sometimes I'm very it depends
on to do this listen I'll just sit
around and listen and just you know I'll
get in the mode when people just do
people will just say crazy [ __ ] and then
but then you have to take that in I just
I'd like to have fun and not do my work
and you know you know tell stories and
tell jokes and do my thing but you
sometimes you don't know how it's hidden
somebody and then you meet somebody and
they say yeah I was going through cancer
for eight months and I was this
listening to your [ __ ] I'm like damn
that's great but when the end your music
get me through I was going through it
and my family left me but yeah have you
had some music yeah I remember I had and
the thing is like you might have a
really [ __ ] gig and just be like [ __ ]
everybody let's hear them wants to talk
to me like I don't get but I remember
one time I was in Baltimore I was in
Baltimore I had like the worst sound in
my life wasn't really shimmered and I
wasn't gonna come back out to do CD
science yes I was just like I'm [ __ ]
done with this [ __ ] and this guy um came
up to me like as I was walking off the
stage to confess that like this is
really heavy by the way but you asked um
something like his dad had like killed
his mom and that that day he had to like
testify in court against his father
yeah and he was like and this was my day
and I just you know I had to be at this
show cuz I really needed it and all this
like superficial diva like [ __ ] [ __ ]
sound like something that I was carrying
was just like [ __ ] man yeah you just
really it's not about you you know all
right and yeah it really kind of shook
me up a little bit like what like yeah
but it's amazing you know like this one
woman how old is he he was young you
would maybe like I mean it was a over 21
show but it was like closer to it yeah
yeah yeah it's just like what do you
even say to this no no charge mate take
the shirt and the CDs but one of my
favorites was there was a woman who
wrote to me from Syria and um it's
already hitting right like nothing
chilling I grow up I grew up and like
have seen my friends and family died and
your music is like a sanctuary for me
and um yeah it's kind of crazy too
because you like I don't know people
will relate to your art in whatever way
like whatever personal [ __ ] they're
going through but that's someone whose
life is so far removed from my life and
they can get something from it it kind
of makes you check yourself yeah you
know and realize how how much of an
impact chechens making on people it's
good it's kind of what gets you through
that [ __ ] yeah I've had lots of sex -
y'all music
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's always great Oh bendin Ilya has sex
do his own music see that's something I
could never do I'm not like he merely he
nearly had sex
oh he does no no like we were on tour
somewhere and he hooked up with someone
like it was like I don't know like Jean
Grey told me don't [ __ ] fans cuz it
always gets weird and like bender and it
like not always this chick and end of it
like a you know like a college dorm
where yeah yeah but you have to share in
shape oh they're people in the room and
like you know she wants it put some mood
music on and then put our [ __ ] on and I
first seen her like it's instrumentals
alright but then like as soon as I
started seeing like it kind of broke you
cuz you're on tour for months at a time
yeah you're kind of like best friends in
light worst enemies so it's just like
you know you don't get down while I yes
yeah does it you know the voice is net
isn't it it's a coworker to him bounce
bounce
he and say hey let's just uh you like
D'Angelo DeAngelo's the staple right
DeAngelo Anderson pie a the Internet is
smooth occasionally I'll throw on a
Flying Lotus Pandora station like the
and listen path is kind of on a nose but
it is and as impact makes kind of it's a
no worries yes I like it so much because
it's almost dirt baggy music and get out
it good yeah I got a cheat on you you
know how he's such a flavor but he's
like you know what it is
sorry [ __ ] yes I was somewhere at the
turn I had to click through that one way
just like you know I think I call you
[ __ ] as long as nobody else called you
a [ __ ] that's too many [ __ ] I like
the one you know I have [ __ ] in my
music but in my singing you gotta be
sparingly Singles can't say [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that much I don't think yeah but
at least it's doing it in a relatively
like chivalrous way isn't if I call you
a [ __ ] it's sad nobody else plenty as
long as nobody else call you [ __ ] if I
give somebody else call you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] miss your phone have you heard
that one with them with the girl talking
about all the different kinds of ways to
like whoop your ass [ __ ] oh you got a
flammable oh yeah this get yeah I like
that I love that I listen to it straight
through it's a smooth and knowledge is
inert to like you listen to lots of
different he always sends me that random
Brazilian or like music from Iran and
[ __ ] he's ahead yeah yeah so what are
y'all in the van do you all I mean
obviously you into music but what I
would I've heard talking to different
bands as they listen sometimes you just
get so tired of music do you listen to
podcasts use a guided meditation no I
mean I like a lot of different music so
there's always something for a different
mood but generally a lot of music from
the Sahara it's really a Sahara
that's a hard does it yeah a lot of my
favorite music comes from there yeah
yeah oh
and because it's like usually in a
language that I can't understand it's
less you can kind of switch your brain
off and just well I mean I can't think
of a Sahara song a lot I feel like in my
humble opinion that a lot of its kind of
like the relative to like the Delta
blues so like a really dry roar good
guitar sounds and just really just yeah
and it's it's often in 6/8 which is kind
of like a cyclical time signature so you
can kind of add up there's less
landmarks you know and so you can kind
of just put it on and turn your brain
off oh nice yeah Maryam Hasan is like
one of my favorite singers Ali [ __ ] -
[ __ ] - yes
oh my managers showing me there's a have
a scene yeah I really want to see but he
has a vinyl of it in its own a remake of
Purple Rain but in the Sahara and it's
called rain the color red with a little
bit of blue in it yeah I just really got
technical about composition of the color
purple life is tough here we don't have
time for these colors and [ __ ] yeah so
it's like literally the narrative of
Purple Rain but with like Sahara and
blues musicians that's right this is
really this is remix of purple white
purple rain by Yo Gotti and Gucci Mane
yo Gotti's already has ice cream face
get his ice cream face gap and yo gotti
is a rapper from memphis and it's a
remix of purple right and I'm sure
Prince didn't clear pure cocaine cocaine
sure Cody can you put it maybe cuz you
know what he didn't know I heard that
the first time I just died but you know
what the fact that it stayed on that
because Prince is very protective of all
of his stuff yes no no he's not on
Spotify or anything yeah yeah yeah yep
yeah it's probably parody long I think
maybe you think y'all got y'all ready
was the after you diet though no this is
about five six years ago yeah I heard I
just dissipate
[Music]
okay the 808 drum tones is beautiful Oda
yes it's a good person so he got on it
okay I didn't this is what you listen to
when you're in your two of us right I'm
all over the place all right that's
enough of that
twelve minutes later this is the rest of
the podcast we use fake conversation we
fake conversations for a little bit I
guess it's okay well it's like a long
verse oh here you go
he's back oh yeah all right cut it cut
that [ __ ] up tears back would you say
traumatic about uh this is know
something we don't understand in
language hmm it's my buddy yeah al
Jackson is touring with us he put us on
his song you know Marcos Valley is he's
my best man I [ __ ] love Marcos father
so much estriol are ya sis wha and yes
so I don't know what he said but his
friend she's put again rather than
go to dance song I wrote a song based on
that yeah I played out in my DJ says
after fire I use these dates and I heads
up into the role of DJ's just come with
you're not [ __ ] with the pure case
I'm that playing oh my god I got a half
hour set tonight I would not play pure
cocaine I will play some stuff that this
should not be played the club just to
have fun but yeah I'll detail of it I
might play extra lot tonight play yeah I
have a song that's based off the court
structure from it really yeah based on
this so what does that mean I'm a dummy
so it's like the harmonics it's like the
harmonics structure so basically you can
copyright lyrics and you can copyright
melody but you know court structures is
just kind of free game cuz it's just
like so many codes that you can use
colors you can okay really I think you
did pull up extra lies so that you can
properly explain to this dummy what the
court structure is on it right yeah cuz
I know I've listened to this on many
many times and so I want to know what
the courts are well I don't know what
they are technically because I don't
have any much gene okay you don't have
any music to it
did you know I don't have any theory
background so I call yeah so you didn't
you didn't learn music no by ear yeah so
she can't just sit here and be like hey
Meyer 7 2 what is music theory it's just
like reading it's the language of music
yeah like being able to read you could
look at a composition and here are like
a Beethoven piece Oh like a lot of
composers would write their [ __ ] down
and then like without even hearing it
and then give it to an orchestra and
then hear it for the first time well I
tried to get into it for a little bit
yeah yeah I play a little bit of keys
but like varying is very minimal but
like I was getting into I was taking
like lessons and I was like really
trying to get into it and that should
just like it just sucks as Amy imploding
like maybe not enjoy music right so I
was like I just I like I would memorize
the song I read the notes memorize the
songs
and just play the songs and be like I
don't want to ever see these notes again
yeah well I mean this it's they're just
tools like the good thing about hiatus
is that you know Simon's been playing
since he was like three whoa play with
other other musicians so they was like
maybe 19 or something what Simon plays
Keys so he was like classically trained
for energy baby notes plays the Rhodes
who plays every kind of synthesizers
yeah just got a mellotron which is like
yeah is that a-- is that a super
expensive key yeah it sounds like it's
drunk it sounds like someone's yelling
to the cartoons I mean you can imagine
you have the card you like ah and he
loaded them to the key doing the press
the book is like opening sound
nessamilan
Strawberry Fields opens a human and I
think other humans do do that like I
just had a lot of myself I'm gonna look
it up and look up a lot of this stuff
they were maker of synthesizers I mean a
theremin what is uh a video of the cat
playing the theremin no yeah does it
kill it
yeah well it's just like does it make
you more excited to play the President
or makes you threatened because you feel
like you can't tell you how to quit
compared to an Internet keV ones
inadequate it's a bit compared to no you
should play the theremin use that [ __ ]
in you bet you
it's like Eugene Mirman already neck
feel like I'm is so is so unique I'd
rather just do it in my so we need
another instrument I used to play the
saxophone
it's been a long time and I tried to
pick it back up my I played at third and
fourth grade and I tried to pick it back
up in college and my mouth was like what
you do can't do this anymore I'm going
to take a drum less I did look up about
the drum teachers in Chicago just to
take a lesson go through with that
yeah classes well on a downtime in
Chicago just get a kit and see what ya
get the kid can go at it yeah just can't
have the gun I have a place for the kid
I wanted to do a side project called
michael jackson death medicine when it's
basically me doing a solo set with a
drum kit but with samurai swords instead
of drum sticks and so the show is just
uni [ __ ] up a drum kit with samurai
swords this is a live show it's a dream
live show you it's a performance it's a
performance piece yeah yeah yeah you
should do it
Yeah right yeah we should do it Koval a
Colby I'm down you want theremin you
yeah you might a Jackson death medicine
Michael Jackson's death medicine and
what I'll do I have a spongebob
characters dance around in a circle on
treadmills yeah well I know while I
throw jacks
on to beat machine Jax is like a crab
like multiple people call Jackie just
wave his hand horns yeah that's like
it's like yeah
[Music]
we a weird music is one of those things
called knuckles here I don't even know I
don't know I just know the object and I
was just trying to think of some weird
to play it's like some spikes and a
bouncy ball you're supposed to hit the
spikes and it's supposed to do some [ __ ]
that's all okay I would like contact my
excitement so you hear all the details
yeah yeah you ever you ever talk to
Prince on the phone he his people
emailed us but I mean it's kind of
[ __ ] we turned down going to Paisley
Park like three times just didn't work
without touring like we'd already had
sold-out shows and like he would he
would basically you know what like see
us on the Ascend your whole show and be
like in three hours come to Paisley Park
we have like a [ __ ] sold-out show and
then we'd have to like do a retaking it
event and so it's just kind of it's not
good for your promoters and your fanbase
personally I was like [ __ ] it let's go
to Prince's house but you know what we
have a whole team and you don't really
want to [ __ ] people over and it's chief
because many ended up coming to our show
you know Minneapolis though because we
didn't go to him that's the thing is I
think Prince gets his way so much that
it's kind of like maybe a good thing
that we never went you know got his way
probably still gets his way right
somewhere in there still goodness when
you're like we can't make he's like all
right whatever man
Grady's wardrobe
when she plays Minneapolis first out
yeah
maybe first that's the ledge that's
where okay it's the one with like
another mezzanine do you not know I mean
the thing when you're on tour is is
countries oh yeah you go a lot of
different how many countries have you
sign again I want to apparently there's
like festivals like music festivals that
are in Iceland and they have like ice
glaciers that are so thick that you can
have really loud music in the so you're
inside of an ice I was great acoustics
and the acoustics it crazy I've always
wanted to do something like that what
country have you ever turned down based
on a country like [ __ ] not Belarus I
think I'd go anyway yeah yeah on trees
that's a lot like yeah all throughout
you sometimes there was like one year we
went to the States maybe like five times
yeah and that's a long [ __ ] was it
what was your favorite city to play out
in the States
[Music]
New York probably New York at the
Gramercy when I was there enjoyed you
insured one of our shows it was [ __ ]
sobering planning urban Plaza no no no
[ __ ] would I show that much like someone
got shot there at a TI constant so
security and everything was really yeah
it's very tight yes no it is somebody
ya know somebody it was I think that
person got killed now this I think they
got kiss you people died in in yeah
outside yeah yeah ed urban Plaza and
then yet a plate there it was it was a
crazy it's how you do tight vile need to
calm down to muggers just got shot I
really like Chicago let maybe the first
time I played in Chicago is it
Dumbledore Dumbledore yeah and it was
[ __ ] awesome ties fight I haven't
played there that was like one of my
favorite shows right now we play Park
West Park West but like I kind of miss
Dumbledore that's more like the Chicago
seen like dumb or empty bottle those
kind of spots yeah like this more like
the Great Divide I don't know I like
sweaty basement like the vibe was a
little cleaner it's a little it's a
Lincoln Park
so yeah more ritzy ER well it's a great
venue but it's just not
I mean London they always London's
pretty cool they always show us up there
yeah like you have people singing guitar
like hot like thousands of people
singing guitar lines [ __ ] oh really
yeah it's crazy people didn't know do
you know who's gonna let her go off
talking about people singing guitar line
so you can't [ __ ] it up because they
know all the bits yeah in London PBS if
you dance - Bam Bam yeah see that's the
thing is our music - really nerdy so
yeah the people that it attracts you
know tend to be like sometimes I'll do
solo shows anyway where is everybody
else is one guy this is like
there's like a woodblock hit that Pez
does in one of the songs already
clapping all the wood because of the
rest of the rhythm like people do an owl
sounds he was so like yeah I'm getting
it right like looking at me like it was
the best thing ever [ __ ] right now
[Music]
seesaw seesaw seesaw seesaw seesaw so a
new online streaming network for seeing
souls would you like to see a soul do
you have a soul that you haven't been
able to see well sign up for seesaw and
you'll be able to see that soul right
away see so has some of the most
unlimited souls you can see souls from
SNL every soul from SNL Late Night with
Jimmy Fallon and The Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon C's so let's go to see so
calm right now SE es Oh calm right now
to sign up for two months free two
months free 60 days for your bitch-ass
promo code Rambla our am BL er a check
on SC SOCOM promo code Rambla two months
free of C so where you can see all the
souls seesaw seesaw seesaw seesaw seesaw
you don't sleep like everybody
he lives mattress is where you can't be
he makes matches yeah yeah yeah mixed
mattress yeah it's like a tailor for a
bed
basically that's it do you like the
tailored suit get a tailored bed it's a
simple concept you get a hundred nights
to try it out or a hundred days
depending on what shift you work and if
you don't like it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a hundred percent
refund no questions asked except for
where do you live at what time should we
pick it up go to helix leap that cop /
member and get $50 off your own that's
helix sleep comm / helix leave coms last
[Music]
you saw saw you read into Herb Dean yeah
at UFC ref on the streets and I was in a
bar near my house yeah yeah but he um I
actually met him before and I forgot if
it happens
yeah and also like oh you don't why I
mean now my sister's a fighter so you
knew him well he came up to you yeah oh
okay he lamb herb D yeah well cuz he saw
his playing uh Santa Anna or some [ __ ]
yeah and then you recognize I know
nothing about Hardy I just know him as
the guy that he didn't killed
really octagon here's the fight like it
was saying he's Australian nice from he
lives in Pasadena oh okay
Pasadena so you guys had a car at the
heart I like that yeah no talk [ __ ] he's
really sweet right yeah and also it's
kind of um did he tell you cool stories
like this one
Rock him so hard his brain was on the
floor he took nights on me cuz they had
this scar and he's had an awesome about
it thinking there would be like a cool
fight story but he was just from your
sister is a kickboxer yeah yeah you
older sister younger sister she's like
two years older than me she's got a five
year old yeah and then like a year ago
it was like something she did just for
fitness and now she's like a title
champion yeah a Victoria champion oh
yeah she's only doing like a year as
well so means competition is horrible
she's really good
she's good she's dedicated I mean also
like I think with women in this sport
it's like like she's had a lot of people
pull out from fight so I like having
that hasn't had anyone to fight her and
stuff somebody couldn't get out of it
bartending shift well I mean yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] crazy the amount of
training that goes with it but I mean
like our mother was a contemporary
choreographer so like you know we grew
up with dance you know I still do ballet
when I was little and got a scholarship
to do it and [ __ ] and yeah so I think
you know a lot of the combinations in
fighting it's like its choreography and
like it's very true you know so I think
naturally because of it like growing up
with that around the house I think it's
something that comes really intuitive to
her she's older younger she's older she
teased or than me okay yeah she have you
two highlights I don't know I mean like
this has been on cable [ __ ] yeah I like
up into some of our fights yeah her
name's the party the party yeah and she
walks out - did she walk out - she walks
out to my [ __ ] Bek
lose track as you walk out to doing
child
boom shower yeah settle it's like I have
you yeah off the first record okay yeah
yeah but she got this like awesome belt
it's like this it kind of looks like the
WWF you
and she said I could borrow it for a
photoshoot a song nice yeah that's
what's that's awesome
yeah she's got like a KO in the first
round and [ __ ] like it's pretty heavy
I mean I don't I don't mind watching
your fight and supporting but whenever
it's like face hits it's kind of like
yeah yeah it's the inner rage of like
I'm gonna [ __ ] that [ __ ] up but it's
like yeah but she's a professional fight
also gonna hurt you too yeah yeah it's
kind of it's it's cool it's gives me
street credit I guess you should show
highlights of her fighting as your
visuals to show you're right yeah oh you
look like a tough chick oh yeah okay
Marshall oh okay
okay skip those ads skip those that skip
skip skip let's go Dean that's why we're
in Oh
okay let's see the walkout I don't think
there's a walk I think that just in the
rain I mean I'm all cats my favorite
part the walk I was important right walk
out is so important yeah for kicking off
show in fighting - mm because you're
gonna get like pumped yeah you get the
adrenaline so I love that my music is
what it is for
yes Megan's at Bellevue where you got
this fight did you watch the fight
[Music]
I think so I want to see them introduce
their she yeah she's a folks - before
they fight it covered their bodies in
tiger balm and pretty much like Megan's
a bell looks like she works at an
organic juice shop that's a lie cuz they
have multiple fights on the same monster
I thought um this guy ko another guy
with an elbow to the face and it was
like a quince and Tarantino film like
blood yeah everywhere and he like I've
never seen the consciousness leave a
person like if you have it so quick it's
crazy but it's always I might really get
our neighborhoods and like my cold
sunshine but really it's like you don't
want to go there yeah and I have I mean
like schedule amounts in like now
Malvina is beautiful it um there's like
a TA be so your sister is a professional
Muay Thai fighter and yen kickboxer Muay
Thai Muay Thai right Mota is kickboxing
is Thai kickboxing yeah and you're
you're a singer yes a singer
taking over the world yeah yeah looks
like you guys are like I feel like
almost like opposite ends like one beats
the [ __ ] out of people at one good she's
actually really Doug singing - yeah
blues [ __ ] yeah Etta James kind of vibe
she know she have oppressed you hi she
I'm saying they put me on the track no
no no I like this one I mean well the
crazy thing is it was so pissed off
about it because I thought I was going
to be in town but to be in the corner in
the ring you have to either be like a
doctor or a health professional or a
fighter or a trainer uh somehow involved
and somehow she hustled it so I could be
in a corner get a mullet just just for
that but yeah listen I was invited to be
in the ring with her and to do that
though you have to learn how for example
like say if she gets like kicked in the
ribs or something yeah and like in the
breaks where you let you know they check
their all their teeth there and the ice
there was a [ __ ] there's a there's a
formula to it because you can't just go
and ice the [ __ ] that hurts because then
they'll know that it's a weakness so
there's like there's all this like code
system or how you ice the body so is so
that the other team team doesn't see
that you're [ __ ] up there right yeah I
didn't know that yeah I mean it makes it
seems like
blood pouring on well yeah but you seem
like it's common sense but yeah didn't
know that yes so like if you're putting
all this attention on the seminary you
know the changes or whatever can see
that and be like you know like she's
really suffering now or whatever but I
um I had a show in New Zealand so I
couldn't go yeah she won that one with
uh why not she's a Victorian champion I
think maybe 7 1 she's only she's only
had maybe like four professional 3 3 104
no it's crazy like she's already like
got offers to fight overseas and stuff
ya know yet no dummy she's been doing a
to you like you know some people just do
it to like get fit or whatever which is
like all the way in like found it well I
don't know I go to hook up so please
could tires yeah yeah that's a great
guitar name actually her birthday yeah
Oh Alan wolf Herb Dean support at
fajitas coyote like I don't know if
there's a Chicago thing but that's not a
good thing to be called someone calls
you a herb as dude what is it like that
means like you a nerd like your loser is
a hard-ass Clara heard ray and nerd like
not in a sense of nerd like that he's
interesting yeah just like you have a
loser yeah yeah that's a coldest place
I've ever been in my whole life I've
been yeah I've been in Russia that's cuz
you turn down a sexist on gig what was
it cuz I could stand Kazakhstan yeah
some kind of like
got a speech impediment um yeah but I
think it's the winds you know yeah yeah
I guess like [ __ ] sub-zero there yeah
you just gotta go there
it isn't whatever it's a relevance of
Moscow it's like 5:00 a.m. middle of
winter and was still cold in Chicago
okay
we don't need a cook today though yeah
it's nice it's nice out here beautiful
you pronounce it correctly most people
like male born
yeah what's going on over here
no born milk I could say to Melbourne
right oh my my accent is it's really
[ __ ] hot in South African mate you
know straight out straight away okay got
my can of like silicon yes
yeah we were having a discussion yeah
I'm a talking but it's closed it's
closed closed through these general I
know it's fine wine and good idea if it
a beer in America just get rid of all
the vowels and it'll be good we will
accept Australian singers and British
singers but British rappers and
Australian rappers and I [ __ ] with this
journey right really but doesn't biggest
cause of the
something about what I like crime [ __ ]
though my little cities near us though
it's no actually little Sims is dope but
it's not like I saw your Sims live at
this festival I saw it this festival in
a Montreal a little Sims is good but it
just doesn't it doesn't dizzy
it what is never what about do dooms
British do originally a module and
British yeah yeah yeah well is a good I
wonder what his day-to-day is like he
can't come back to America really yeah
he lives in London I would wonder what
MF dooms day to day life is like smokes
drinks and lives on it you don't know
him man a character masks on would you
come inside a photo of the inside of his
mosque and it's like all amethyst like
amethyst and what this is like a purple
crystal and a hole inside of his mosque
is laid with it that's all the masks
I seen a photo of it yeah yes and yeah
and it's supposedly to stop him from
like psychic attacks so he might be like
a little bit like religious [ __ ] he's
crazy to be that good he's a good kind
of crazy he's the best MC saying that
guy smokes and drinks every day he's
unhealthy [ __ ] you don't have no he
don't have no Instagram or Twitter you
know he don't have you don't have a
youtube channel
when is he that when you've seen him
live last seen at the metro yeah exactly
ours back you're not alone people lose
40 pounds in a month it was all like I
listen
listen MF DOOM if you listening more
friends of MF DOOM tawny trim is super
judgemental and says you drink it's no
I'm not I'm not gonna just accept that
I'm not gonna accept that as what's your
day-to-day like this but we should do a
documentary man
yeah MF DOOM Hannibal Burres trap
what about toward would MF DOOM across
Europe can michael jackson death
medicine be a sub michael jackson death
medicine yes let me on the bill yeah you
got a leverage night napalm with that
[Laughter]
have enough experimental hands
straightforward samurai sword it also be
expensive to have to get a new drum kit
ever each other huh how much is a junket
listen listen what's the main drum
company yamaha a yamaha sponsor are sure
i needed I need a samurai sword we need
a source we need samurai swords we need
drum kits we need direct contact with MF
DOOM we need cameras we need flights
whoever Delta we need sponsors hit up
the handsome ramble at gmail.com and you
can book me napalm and inner MF DOOM if
you listening yes that napalm thank you
so much it was amazing
talking to you anything check out what's
your sister's name again the party
Beckman look the party back McLaughlin
McLaughlin and check out all of the
music hiatus coyote their last album
choose your weapon amazing album smooth
my favorite tracks molasses well
obviously that's your favorite I think
I'd like dedicated to ones yeah yeah I
felt it the lung-lung I was on a date
two of the top
I love that [ __ ] though I love giving
people shouting points of this
significant other yes at one time I went
terribly [ __ ] wrong where I was in
Vegas and the sky rush it was I can a
called insert coins was i god yeah yes
it was awesome but this guy hit me up
and he wanted to propose to his girl oh
yeah I love love of course I'll do it
and my color up and she's losing her
chick she doesn't know why she's being
called up what's up
That's not me no that's not me tell you
[ __ ] so um yeah and so I could you know
like we're playing Mobius chick was like
a favorite gem and I I call her up no
Mike you know such and such as somebody
wants to say in hall room was that waste
and just like whoa like you know any any
hostile to marry him and then she
doesn't say anything and just like they
both awkwardly walk off the stage and I
was like what does she say cuz there's a
whole room of people that are waiting to
you you know the answer and he's like oh
she said she'll think about it
and then later I found out that they're
related only been dating like five
months and their relationship was on the
rocks and like he was that was like to
try and save their relation you have it
going tiny they're in solid and then
like I embarrassed her for the rest of
the night I might never have to keep the
show going yeah just try to play it off
[Music]
[Applause]
like young thuggish no no
are you coming to the show tonight yeah
okay good rap you don't see us much
closer Oh gibberish rap it's a hit
single it hit number hit number one in
Norway wait yes it is I rap on this
podcast all the time actually this is
the least I've rap
forget about are you crazy you know so
yeah I do this song and at the end of my
set there's a couple years ago I think
it was Virginia Beach it was a show or
something rich in and so they this is
what happens at comedy clubs which makes
me glad that I don't do them that much
anymore I still do them occasionally but
I mostly do theatres and music videos a
condom gangsta like that Sileo are
sinners it feels great because comedy
clubs have their own set thing and they
will ask you [ __ ] there's a oh it's such
a such birthday can you shout them out
yeah I don't know what that fits in my
[ __ ] so oh yeah oh this guys getting he
wants to propose to his girlfriend can
you work that into your our set like how
does this guy's proposal fit and so I
said okay I'm not his gonna [ __ ] in
my set and say this guy wants to say
something I'm not gonna do it in the
middle of my set I'm not gonna do
relationship jokes
oh speaking of relationships this guy is
in a very serious one and he wants the
second or next level
Jeremy come right up here so I said okay
he could propose but uh it'll be after I
do the songs every I do it five times
like after the third one I'm or five
times it's very short passage and is
this what a pyrotechnics I
I have ballerinas and sometimes I have
we almost have fire once this is
pyrotech you know pirate was like $5,000
a hit just let's go ice and dollars I
used to be a fire dancer before like I
said dazzle fire at a place called
science works it's kind of like a
planetarium kind of way yeah and as um
one of the staffs had like fireworks on
it and it was a hundred bucks for like
one bird Wow
like just in fuel and [ __ ] yeah yeah
this is very expensive so we just
figured it out when we said okay after
the third wouldn't have to do it
acapella I'm gonna act like I need a
hype man from the crowd I'm gonna bring
you up and then you could do it is so I
did the song and I like a pretty I want
I need a new hype man come on and his
guy comes on stage and he grabs the mic
he said a baby I wanna you know a little
dog and holliness and I love you and
will you marry me and then she says yes
she said yeah Tony hit the beat again
and he just is cute yeah yeah it wasn't
smooth at all he's never actually want
to hit them up on Facebook see how the
marriage is going good
see anyways thanks a lot again thank you
hey Tony Sriram hey Charlie Parker check
out all hiatus coyote music check out
their tour dates when they go back out
on tour 20 all torn again six months no
Sam just relax it yeah I mean we're
recording Schillings
well we haven't it's [ __ ] like sucks
what kind of at a point where we just
like we're gonna make some music and I
do random solo shows when I want to get
a new tattoo somewhere
like the end of the year so yeah well if
also thank you they did the intro music
for why yeah my short lived between yeah
I was like five days at home I was like
PS you want to do this like just kind of
like thank you guys wrote that for the
show yeah well for the show yeah
so if you uh wouldn't you want when
y'all in the recording process I'm not
gonna be out here but if you ever need
me to send in yoga huh y'all get it look
it yeah cuz it's like it's like you're
talking with yoga in your mouth
you never know yeah auto-tune show your
auto-tune skills well you get like that
laughs hey do you see if it needs or
don't you know that that is
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
everybody was wondering this is Rob
bubbles in panel a very good singer it
off pain was like an MPR she pays a
really good essay yeah I can sing well
the photos just like here in Toronto so
I did it made its Millions
what's the Australia have you suddenly
Australian national you all sing it
somewhere you get off it to sing it and
you think auto-reply no would you like
doesn't it no just this is auto-reply of
napalm no nationally wow I mean like
it's like I feel like there's a you know
there's like one of the lyrics is about
there's lots of land to share and all
this [ __ ] okay and it's like we have
like one of the worst policies on
refugees yeah I came to do this issues
that [ __ ] sir I'm not about to be
ranting some it's not my bad yeah you
have CNN don't ask her the same
at her sisters kick box of matches isn't
that going down alright please don't
I just wanna thank you helix helix
yeah helix com thank you for your mind I
want to spin it on soup and a pair of
newly discounted Yeezys helix leaps
allow you to buy a completely customized
matches online for hundreds of dollars
in that thousands your matches will
arrive at your door in about a week and
shipping is a hundred percent free you
have a hundred nights to try it out
that's such a biblical amount of time
100 nights they'll pick it up for free
and give you a hundred percent refund no
questions
go to helix leave cops last ramble and
get $50 off your first order
that's helix sleep calm slash hello I'm
Chris Gethard and here with me as dream
analysis expert Gary Richardson and we
are here to give you a taste of a brand
new podcast called in your dreams
presented exclusively by the fine folks
at Casper we listen to the wildest
weirdest dreams are made it to us by you
our listeners and we do our best to
figure out just what those dreams could
possibly mean Lewis and the news you're
saying this person might have interests
in style and fashion specifically you
can say all that from that voicemail 99%
certainty plus we'll be joined by some
very special guests the word brutality
comes to mind
mortality blood blood tality subscribe -
in your dreams right now on iTunes or
wherever you get your podcast thanks for
listening good night
this has been an ear wolf production
executive produced by Scott Aukerman and
Chris Bannon for more information and
content visit Earwolf dot-com
you